all right joining us now he's a really
big deal
i know i'm told this i'm not very pop
cultured i'm sorry
comedian movie star author and host of
the show brand
x russell brand this summer he's
embarking on his first ever worldwide
comedy tour
the messiah complex katy kay and brian
schachman are here as well and he
already told brian that he might want to
disrobe
i'm just saying i just thought maybe i
could loosen up a little show a little
more chest hair and he said maybe i
should i only think russell can do that
you look fantastic
that is a very kind compliment you also
look beautiful
brian you are free to wear whatever you
want this is one of your freedoms that
is afforded to you i appreciate that
uh oh silver boots the boots are i want
to see
them come on put them on the table kinky
boots wow
there are some boots those are nice
relax i wouldn't do that i don't want to
disrespect your program okay no no
no no i didn't and i like fellow english
woman and we don't oblige
talked about kinky boots recently yes
it's a fantastic show you have to go
okay roswell oh sorry about that you
just last
um it's like your desk is a puzzle it is
i'm sorry about that what is the
solution
i think can't we get like you know 30
seconds
now well not really love i mean
i hope that's not your message too
gandhi and the people of india
no you know it's it's funny though
because i i travel a lot
and these people are at work are they
yeah they're just at work more quietly
they're facebooking actually what are
they doing facebooking
they're facebooking yeah yeah shopping
they can't look at pornography i bet
it's blocked on their website
well i don't know i mean you have a
pretty broad range here i'm going to ask
a serious question can i try i'll try
it's never good everyone asks what do
you like better tv
movies or stand up which actually which
one's more difficult
i mean going on stage i think is
probably pretty tough movie can be
boring because you shoot a thing 100
times tv
is what it is there are challenges in
all of those different disciplines the
thing i enjoy most is stand-up comedy
because you're direct with your
audience you can't be misinterpreted
people can't get confused
you know what happens if you work in
media people like to
change the information so that it suits
a particular agenda if you're in a room
with people then what you're saying is
clear if you say something that people
that people are confused about you can
explain it to them then
if you say something because a joke
people can't pretend that you're saying
it seriously
so i like having direct communication
with people because i believe people are
very very intelligent
but like the information gets
manipulated a lot and people like to
cause like you know
fake stirs and stuff you know funny the
accent you know
when i see him in person it's totally
fine forgetting sarah marshall or the tv
show it's fine
but on satellite radio in the car i
can't understand a single joke
you can't understand it can you i can't
stand me yes but
i'm telling when i'm driving in the car
and he's everyone's laughing in the
audience at the radio i'm like i have no
idea what he's doing he's best you focus
on your driving right
you're a man you don't want to be
distracted by humor you might crash into
a pedestrian so it's a good thing
i think it's probably for the best i
think i'm just
my this is my first um brand experience
brand
yeah i think it's not listening to him
it's it's it's experience it's just sort
of taking it all in
you are talking about me as if i'm not
here and as if i'm an extraterrestrial
you know i'm from a country that's near
dummy we're just sort of admiring the
whole you know it's the whole thing
well thank you for your casual
objectification it's an experience
i'm glad that it is positive for you
very positive absolutely
anymore any other questions you've
become nervous
why are you nervous you're a powerful
woman you've got a lovely job what seems
to be the trouble
you've got a hair like princess diana oh
wow okay
well i've never when she was alive
here's a little subtext yes
i'm petrified of her and you have her
honor she's just moved down there i
absolutely love this
russell brand was clearly provoked
during this interview however he handled
the situation masterfully by
creating and at times even imposing his
own reality on the journalists
he was absolutely calm whilst
artistically handling
all the arguments thrown at him and he
managed to reframe the discussion to
make it fit his own narrative
that is the quintessence of frame
control
framing is a technique that almost all
high performance speakers
use to control the flow and outcome of a
conversation in crucial setting
situations
the importance of owning the frame
simply cannot be understated
it's how the media gets you to believe
their angle on a particular story
it's how politicians outperform their
opponents it's how influential people
communicate their influence to others
one's capacity for personal decisions
lifestyle choices
emotional investments religious beliefs
and political inclinations are all
influenced by our proclivity
towards certain frames what i want to
discuss today is how to become
completely aware of the concept of frame
in order to improve the way you
communicate but also understand the way
others are trying to influence you
get their message across and win debates
you can think of your frame as a window
frame that you are constantly looking
through
as you move the frame around the stimuli
that you encounter
are interpreted by your brain in ways
consistent with your beliefs
values and identity this is your
perspective or
point of view in every human
relationship each individual projects
his or her own personal frame
when different frames face off beliefs
values
ideas and instincts collide your frame
because it somehow represents your
identity
is something very dear to you it
constitutes the substrate of your belief
system and
when it is questioned it feels as if
someone convulses the foundation of your
being
that's not an easy thing to accept so
your ego gets triggered and you react
you experience a fight or flight
response you become defensive
competitive
and you want your view to be respected
our whole existence can be interpreted
as a perpetual struggle to assert frame
control
it can be exhausting not just
experiencing it firsthand
but also even watching it being
performed by other people
nonetheless properly fathoming and
applying when needed the power frame
is one of the most important
communication mechanisms one can ever
learn
no truth is more absolutely certain than
that all that exists for knowledge and
therefore
this whole world is only object in
relation to subject
perception of a perceiver in a word idea
the world is idea that's what
sophenhauer wrote in the world as
william representation
and willingly or unwillingly he
attempted to introduce us to the concept
of frame
he wasn't the first one to do it though
brain wars have been practiced
extensively in ancient greece when
people were trying to influence others
in the famous agora
the tactics and the delivery may have
evolved through time
but the main principles of frame control
remain
more or less the same these principles
were also adopted by russell brown
during his interview
hence i chose the name the russell brown
method for this video
and they're as follows a robust belief
system
a strong body language clarity and
presence
and an ability to capitalize on weak
arguments
let's take it off this in turn for
further analysis
maintaining frame is nearly impossible
without a unifying worldview
or a philosophy of life if you will lack
of a robust belief system is usually to
blame when we lose our frame during a
conversation
if you have managed to create a strong
life philosophy and you're practicing it
on an ongoing basis
you will eventually form a strong
opinion around it
you will be able to support your
arguments without hesitation because
you're well versed in your subject and
your arguments represent you and your
fundamental beliefs
they are an extension of your lifestyle
so to speak an adherence to a strong
belief system
is the reality behind every single frame
battle it is evident when politicians
debate
when priests evangelize their religious
beliefs
and when business people try to pitch
their product in the case of russell
brand for instance
this is clearly exhibited when he
explains the reason he prefers stand-up
comedy to tv or cinema
there are challenges in all of those
different disciplines the thing i enjoy
most is stand-up comedy because you're
direct with your
audience you can't be misinterpreted
people can't get confused
you know what happens if you work in
media people like to uh
change the information so that it suits
a particular agenda if you're in a room
with people then what you're saying is
clear if you say something that people
that people are confused about you can
explain it to them then
if you say something because a joke
people can't pretend that you're saying
it seriously
so i like having direct communication
with people because i believe people are
very very intelligent
but the information gets manipulated a
lot and people like to cause like you
know
fake stirs and stuff he artfully
explains why stand-up comedy is so
special
compared to other forms of entertainment
and ensures that his reasoning is deeply
rooted in his own belief system and
overall world view
body language sub-communicates one's
emotional state throughout the
conversation and
that can have a huge impact on oneself
while exercising frame control
firstly an open chest while leaning back
which allows the person to avoid
slouching can be extremely helpful
having an open upright chest with
uncrossed arms is a very strong pose
that
communicates confidence crossing one's
arms is a defensive pose and is usually
perceived as weak and insecure
secondly a deeper voice can help people
engage with the speaker and pay
attention
vocal tonality has the capacity to evoke
specific feelings and
reveal a hint of one's identity through
their words
it is this underlying factor that gives
a different color to one's messages and
reinforces one's image and rhetoric
thirdly hand movements and gestures can
be used extensively
to enhance one's credibility and
persuasiveness our brain is capable of
sensing the slightest hand and finger
movement and
during a conversation or a speech if
hands and gestures are used effectively
they can empower the delivery of a
message
centuries ago the brilliant philosopher
william of ockham
stated the importance of reducing things
to their simplest elements
entities shall not be multiplied beyond
need
it is futile to explain with many things
what can be explained by
only a few things this simple yet
profound concept has influenced many
great thinkers and has
frequently revealed its importance
within the context of a frame battle
especially in debates great speakers
know that the key
is to reduce things to their simplest
elements they focus on what they can
control not on what they cannot
they focus on their strengths not their
weaknesses and whenever they don't have
a great answer
they reframe the question to something
opposite to their narrative
overanalyzing overthinking and
overcomplicating can instill doubt and
hesitation in one's mind
it can force a speaker to submit to
their emotions
overwhelming them and affecting their
stream of reasoning
russell brand apart from possessing a
robust belief system
is also a very resilient person his
clarity is rock solid and
even if it sometimes appears that he
will lose the frame
his presence helps him recover smoothly
he clearly demonstrates this ability
when he is referred to as a shop window
dummy by gary kaye co-host of the
morning show
taking it all in you are talking here
about me
if i'm an extraterrestrial you know i'm
from a country that's near
dummy we're just sort of admiring the
whole you know it's the whole thing
well thank you for your casual
objectification it's an experience
bran's response thank you for your
casual objectification
is simply masterful
debates interviews and verbal
confrontations can get ugly and
challenging
a calm state as discussed earlier offers
clarity of thought
if a speaker is unaffected by the
insults and provocations people throw at
him or her
he or she can gain a competitive
advantage not only because people can
perceive him or her
as a calm and resilient figure but also
because he or
she will have time to evaluate their
words and use them as counter arguments
frame control is basically an exercise
in composure
again this is demonstrated exceptionally
by russell brand when co-host
brian shachman tries to pick on bran's
accent by suggesting that
he cannot understand the word he says
when listening to him on the radio
you know funny the accent you know when
i see him in person
it's totally fine forgetting sarah
marshall or the tv show it's fine
but on satellite radio in the car i
can't understand a single joke
you can't understand it can you i can't
stand me yes but
i'm telling when i'm driving in the car
and he's like everyone's laughing in the
audience at the radio i'm like i have no
idea what he's doing
it's best you focus on your driving
right you're a man you don't want to be
distracted by humor you might
crash into a pedestrian so it's a good
thing i think it's probably for the best
unaffected by the comment bran sees the
opportunity and reverses the frame
dynamic
by mocking such man's inability to
multitask and suggesting that it is
actually for the best
that he doesn't understand his jokes a
truly amazing comeback
frame control is just a reminder of how
we're constantly sabotaged by our own
nature
the world is indeed an idea and we just
end up fighting each other over
different ideas our ego is the enemy
here ergo
a frame battle is essentially an ego
battle and because our egos are still
very strong
frame battles will never end especially
when we encounter egos that are so big
and can become so powerful that
we need to use opposing egos just to
attenuate their power
unfortunately we can get rid of the ego
at least when we use it to support our
frame
let's make sure that it is used for a
good cause let's make sure that our ego
won't end up being wasted on the wrong
side of history
hey guys hope you enjoyed today's video
if you did make sure to like subscribe
turn on notifications and comment below
something cool please so that
more people can discover it if you want
to watch more videos from my channel
check out this one and this one take
care see you soon either now
you